i guess the purpose of this talk is to
give you some sense of what uh you could
talk to me about
so i'm gonna try to give you a little
bit of an overview um i'm interested in
a lot of things uh broadly computational
statistics but lots of aspects of it
robust statistics basic statistics lots
all things high dimensional
a lot of heavy tailed statistics
and i actually have broad interest in
theory of computing beyond that so uh
the the world is full of statistics
problems um some of them seem to be
computationally easy some of them seem
to be computationally hard like for some
reason if you plant a leak of size
one-third in an air-to-trainee random
graph on and vertices it seems like it's
computationally hard to find it but like
if you plan to think of size rudin then
it's like computationally easy and
that's like kind of crazy
what's that
yeah
yeah you should put the two thank you
that's a good i made that slide two
minutes ago so i really appreciate it
thank you yeah so um my standards for
accuracy and research are very high uh
anyway you know this is this is the edge
of tractability between uh between easy
and harm problems sorry everyone
um
and and a major goal of my research is
to figure out you know
where where is this edge what are the
best algorithms and what are the reasons
that problems become hard when you cross
it
so
uh
there are kind of two themes as we
approach the edge of tractability from
both sides and i i think about both in
my research the first theme is algorithm
design um
you know the where the goal is to
understand where the edge of
tractability lies by designing
computationally efficient algorithms for
statistics problems with the strongest
possible proofable guarantees
and ideally to do so using unified
algorithm design principles and the set
of algorithm design principles that i
think about a lot goes under the name
the sum of squares method it's a way to
utilize powerful convex programming
techniques coming from mathematical
optimization
to solve statistics problems that's
something i'm happy to talk to you about
it seems it's seen a great deal of
use in algorithm designs for
computational statistics over the last
uh five years or so
so i thought i would give you a really
quick example of
a result of mine from now from a couple
of years ago using this sum of squares
method to solve a very basic problem in
computational statistics and even though
this result is now a couple of years old
it's inspired a lot of work of
the things that i've worked on actually
some things that others have done
using the techniques to design
algorithms for
less simple situations so
um
this is a result
for a very simple problem i want to
estimate the mean of a high dimensional
random vector so i'm from independent
samples so there's some probability
distribution d in high dimensions like
little d dimensions i get some n
independent samples from it i want to
estimate its mean and all i'm going to
assume about this distribution is that
it has bounded covariance so it might
not even have a third moment the third
moment might be infinite
um
and uh
i would like to estimate
the mean by some estimator mu hat and i
would like to get small confidence
intervals for for the mean so i'd like
to i'd like mu hat to be close to mu uh
with good probability with probability
like 1 minus delta and the reason for
this funny expression this is the
distance that you should be is that this
is the distance that you would be to the
mean if you made a stronger assumption
the vector is gaussian and you use the
empirical mean which would be the
optimal estimator so these are the best
confidence intervals that you can hope
for and the question is can you do this
while making much fewer assumptions on
the underlying random variable if you
just allow just assume that it is
bounded covariance and you know the
empirical mean won't do it
right the empirical mean is way too um
way too sensitive to outliers in your
sample set in order to obtain this kind
of confidence intervals when delta gets
small the empirical mean is basically
only greater than x is subgaussian
it turns out though that if you use a
more sophisticated estimator if you use
some some notion of a high dimensional
median
you can actually kind of remarkably
achieve this this was a result proved
only pretty recently by lugosi and
mendelssohn in 2017 so even though this
is a problem that could have been stated
you know by pearson pretty much like
this was only resolved like three years
ago um
so you can use some high dimensional
median which gives you these
statistically optimal confidence
intervals at least up to the hidden
constant
but it seems to be computationally
infeasible like two key medians and
things like this isn't exactly a two key
median but two it's sort of too
comedian-like and things like that you
know are very computationally expensive
so
uh
the the result
was that it turns out that you don't
have to employ the the computationally
intractable version of high dimensional
median um actually there exists a
polynomial time algorithm that achieves
these same information theoretically
optimal confidence intervals making only
the assumption that the underlying
random vector has two has two finite
moments um so there's essentially like
one way to view this is that there is
not only is there no statistical cost to
being robust to these very weak
assumptions there's also no
computational cost you don't have to
spend exponential time or anything like
that
um and as i hinted at before
the the approach to design this
algorithm was not ad hoc it's really
based on this unified technique for
algorithm design and statistics called
the sum of squares method which i don't
have time to describe in any detail but
i'm very happy to talk to anyone about
okay so
uh
can anybody spot the bug in this slide
okay uh so we said that you know the
world is full of easy problems we're all
just full of computational problems uh
some of them are easy some of them seem
like they're hard and the second theme
in my research i have like three minutes
is that right
yeah yeah okay
the second theme in my research is to
approach the edge of tractability from
the other direction
uh
and
in statistics there you know this is
kind of a new field how do you show that
a statistics problem is computationally
hard what kind of evidence can you
establish for it well that's sort of
what this program is about but a kind of
evidence that i've thought about a lot
is if you have unified powerful
algorithm design techniques that seem to
capture the best available algorithms
for lots of problems at once then
unconditionally ruling out algorithms
based on those techniques for a
seemingly hard problem is at least
strong evidence that to solve that
problem you would have to invent
something totally new and maybe it's
even evidence that that problem is
straight up computationally and feasible
so my work is focused on doing that
actually uh
one one piece of work i did now five
years ago was exactly about this planted
cleat problem that i mentioned on the
cartoon slide where we showed that this
sum of squares method doesn't is not
able to do things like find n to the one
third size cliques in um
in aris rainy graphs
uh
and instead of telling you an example
thing that i proved on this theme i want
to tell you an example problem that i
really like
uh we heard a little bit already
probably at the boot camp about
hypothesis testing problems in high
dimensions which are not solved by
looking at low degree moments of the
underlying distributions that you want
to test so there's this
low degree conjecture that's floating
around that says that if low degree
polynomials don't solve some high
dimensional hypothesis testing problem
you know think just like
an error training graph versus narrative
radiograph with a planted clique there's
this there's this very strong conjecture
floating around that says that's
actually you know if low degree
polynomials don't solve the problem then
polynomial time algorithms don't solve
the problem
and i would love to establish some
version of this conjecture
unconditionally
when you restrict from convex from
polynomial time algorithms to some of
square's convex programs we could hope
to unconditionally rule out these
powerful algorithms under a very mild uh
criterion on uh on an underlying
hypothesis testing problem so a major
goal of mine this semester is to try to
make a little bit of progress on this
sum of squares version of the low degree
conjecture and i'm happy to talk to
people about it
um
in case there in case you don't want to
talk to me about those things you could
talk to me about discrepancy i'm super
into discrepancy recently you could talk
to me about combinatorial optimization
i've thought a little bit about
indistinguishability obfuscation and
cryptography
and i also really like to talk about and
ride bicycles so you can talk to me
about that too if all else fails
um finally a super short plug we have a
workshop on a lot of this stuff next
week uh called rigorous evidence for
information computation trade-offs
there's gonna be a lot of awesome talks
um and i promise none of the speakers
are going to invert easy and hard
problems like i did so the talks will be
super accurate
uh
great i hope to see you all there that's
all
[Applause]
thanks sam um
yeah this is a super quick question
but otherwise
people just keep that party rolling yeah